はあああうっとうしもう髪の毛が長いし金髪が来てきました
肇社長ですちょっとしたらもうすぐも金髪やべるんで今のうちに
スクそしておいて皆さんは書ペンを食べますがショップ
シャークペアならさまざまな出版が世の中にはありますよパスコの超熟とかねあ喰らう
菊富士パナ樽仕込みダブルソフトとこれは何か昔からうっぽいなぁ
ヤマザキパンのほう山崎者でも山崎淳一世の中にはいろんな食感があるわけでそこなら
ば俺みたいにでチー世界の神となる俺みたいに神となると
食べ物に微妙な違いにも気づく地域食パン
ショッパーが味を僕が何が当てます今から今なければ俺はネットステータスという
食べ物小さな細かい違い味のわかる男になるわけですよ
今までいろんなれない声でやってるんですけどもその失敗に終わってます今回は決める
ぜジャイ子
こちらの6種類風合いショップぱんちょうじ
9 the full とストラ払った仕込み植えるフレットは本仕込み柔らかが2つ
あるの花ちゃんふうわりと柔らかなじゃあさっそくちょっと味見タイムですくう狩り
ショパンから生まれっていうぐらいだからわかりやすいたもんだ言っていただきます
が踏ん張りしているとショップパンって基本的に味があんまりないんで小さな味を覚え
ておら9風にこんなにあまりな長寿ちょっと答えかな
その橋は椎名生まれちょっとはなかったじゃこっちは香ばしいぞあんまり甘くない
ちょっと大人の味ですね朝食はダブルソフト
あーやは夏山なさい謎一覧なんでもないよだめソフトは何でもないですよちょっとねえ
か
バー
んよ貴方仕込み座は立たずクビだトップ針がさせていただきます
なんか急速にんでそういう所とぅ給食感がありますねつぎロイヤルブレッド出版の耳の
た縁から学んだ何か何かを感じ何かおっ
これは無理かもしれないやそんなことねーぞ
全部同じフジパンの本仕込みいきます腰パンもつぼみ
オーナーなって多分で微妙な違いはあるかもしれないけどやっぱ同じねあの日が違って
いうのは違って本著今回笑えないわ
今回やばい本当に学んだちょっともう一度します
本塾に美味しいのかなこれねーぞタワー本当に美味しいですねあとでも美味しいで全部
おいしい
俺これ大丈夫かなぁかってぃショットパンがわかりやすいように目印を付けました
このコップに食パンを入れて僕が目が苦笑してこれは何かを当てます
ちょ最初はじめチェックもうちょっと始めさせてください優しいね風磨2階は優しい
超熟はちょっと苦いまたこれ料金等にしなきゃなんかアレで二世とか言われそう
全部同じくらいで両でしょ全部を出し切られるよねよしバッチリだってたら俺ほぼのだ
ぞ
俺は今回さんどうもはじめした以前と違うからな行くぞ
見えませんかね見えませんからねよっしゃいきますショップスター
んだからっ
それ落ちた大塚パッたったよしとと思いました
では
実食これから取るから来ますこれから行けます
yeah
part いいでしょあ
あ
これわかるかもいただきます
me
さあわかる
おおおおおおお
た
持っています
金田フーディ食パン
0 c
あロイヤルフレット3個目ロイヤルブレッドです
打った瞬間を買った